comencemos comentando estos primeros
estimaciones de resultados de la primera
vuelta electoral que resaltaría usted de
esta votación
pues daniela me parece que
hoy en día vamos con una nueva asamblea
tres polos
juntos la plataforma ma cronista la nube
es esa unión plataforma de izquierda
y luego mucho más lejos
las derechas ahora esa confrontación
como bien se dijo es inédita porque el
bloque de izquierda está liderado por la
extrema izquierda
que empujó porque vemos bien en las
proyecciones de sillas para la segunda
vuelta dentro de una semana que la
plataforma de la mayoría de lo que desde
el poder de la mayoría presidencial
sale encabezando la próxima asamblea
vamos en lo peor para ellos a una
mayoría relativa
a una corta mayoría absoluta ya que en
francia en el parlamento la mayoría
absoluta es de
289 dictados y las proyecciones revelan
de una posibilidad de 255 hasta 295
entonces es electricidad que captamos
esa noche a los resultados es porque ya
esa la mayoría va a ser reactiva o más
corta
va a haber tensiones con el bloque de
izquierdas sin duda entonces ahí va a
haber unos debates mucho más fuertes que
durante los cinco últimos años donde la
plataforma presidencial tenía una larga
amplia mayoría absoluta lo que le
permitió llevar a cabo el programa de
manuel marco cuando desde 2017
te va a tener que debatir el parlamento
va a tener que tomar su papel es decir
el debate promoción de proyectos de ley
para la mayoría y por supuesto pues
denunciar los proyectos por una
oposición que va a ser una oposición de
izquierda último punto la abstención
desgraciadamente fuerte 53 por ciento es
algo totalmente inédito